hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
eine der häufigsten Fragen bei meinem
nachgemacht Video war Sally kann sie
nicht mal eine Spaghetti Eistorte
nachmachen dazu gibt es nämlich eine
Backmischung von Dr Oetker und das ist
übrigens nicht gesponsert
ich glaube so lustig war Torte
dekorieren noch nie
[Musik]
und dabei geht es gar nicht darum eine
Backmischung schlecht zu machen
Backmischungen sind super vor allem wenn
ihr keine Zeit habt wenn ihr keine Lust
habt 20 Zutaten zu kaufen das Mehl steht
rum die Eier stehen rum die Butter ist
offen und dafür ist es ganz gut geeignet
man hat Backmischungen es ist alles
perfekt abgewogen ganz einfach in der
Zubereitung und selbst Menschen die
nicht kochen und backen können
normalerweise Backmischungen zubereiten
so jetzt geht's aber erstmal ans
Tortenrezept und laut Backmischung muss
ich erstmal einen Rührkuchen herstellen
und zeige euch mal kurz die Zutaten
dafür verwendet ihr 100 Gramm weiße
Butter 100 g Zucker etwas Salz und
Vanilleextrakt zwei Eier etwas Milch und
100 g Mehl Backpulver oder ihr nehmt
einfach das backmehl zuerst die weiche
Butter und verwirrt sie mit dem Zucker
Salz und Vanilleextrakt für etwa 5 bis 6
Minuten weiß cremig
dann kommen nacheinander die Eier dazu
da achtet ihr bitte drauf dass die
eierraumtemperatur haben ansonsten
gerinnt euch nämlich die Masse
anschließend kommt es auch die Milch
dazu mehl und Backpulver schön verrühren
oder wenn ihr das backmehl verwendet
müsst ihr gar nichts mehr verrühren und
könnt einfach alles kurz nur noch
vermischen den Teig füllt ihr dann in
eure vorbereitete Springform ein ich
nehme jetzt hier meinen Tortenring und
habe den spring vom Boden drunter das
ganze auf 25 cm eingestellt schön glatt
streichen und im vorgeheizten Ofen
backen oder wenn ihr einen Bosch
Backofen habt einfach mit backsensor
backen
der Boden ist gebacken und abgekühlt
jetzt kann ich hier die Creme zubereiten
in der oetker Mischung ist quasi eine
Vanillecreme es sind Erdbeerstücke oder
erdbeer-würfel mit dabei ich habe das
jetzt schon gewürfelt und dann kommt da
ja diese Spaghetti Technik drauf mit
Erdbeersoße und der ähm ich würde sagen
dem Käse aber ja ist ja eigentlich Käse
Ersatz im Sinne von Schokolade weiße
Schokolade ich zeige euch mal kurz meine
Zutaten ihr braucht dafür 400 g kalte
Schlagsahne 50 g Puderzucker
Vanilleextrakt Sana passt zum steif
schlagen und 400g Erdbeeren ihr nehmt
jetzt die kalte Schlagsahne gibt
Puderzucker Vanilleextrakt dazu und dann
schlagt ihr die Creme mit seiner
[Musik]
fertig ist die Sahne ein Drittel davon
gebe ich jetzt in den Spritzbeutel mit
einer Lochtülle ihr könnt aber auch
einen Spritzbeutel ohne Lochtülle
verwenden oder einen Gefrierbeutel wenn
ihr das nicht da habt und später einfach
eine Ecke wegschneiden ist einfach die
Erdbeeren unter die Sahne unterheben
dann nehme ich jetzt den Boden der kommt
auf meine Tortenplatte
ich würde jetzt wäre es so ein reines
Sally Rezept ich würde den Boden
durchschneiden
Erdbeermarmelade drauf streichen und den
Boden wieder draufsetzen denn ich
persönlich finde der Boden ist einfach
ein bisschen zu dick für
für dass das dann oben drauf nur die
Creme ist und ich würde sagen ich mache
das auch ich mache da jetzt kurz
Erdbeermarmelade zwischen
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt die Creme mit den
Erdbeeren Kuppel für mich obendrauf wie
bei so einem Maulwurfkuchen
[Musik]
ja
jetzt kommt eigentlich der coole Part
nämlich
mit dem Spritzbeutel wieso Spaghetti Eis
einfach drauf spritzen
[Musik]
ich glaube so lustig war Torte
dekorieren noch nie
also jetzt kommt schon das kriegt echt
jeder hin das ist einfach so wahllos
drauf spritzen die Creme auf die Torte
okay die kommt kurz in den Kühlschrank
ich kümmere mich noch um die Erdbeersoße
da brauche ich einfach Erdbeeren
bisschen Zucker bisschen Vanilleextrakt
dafür
mega easy hier für die Erdbeersoße nehme
ich 100 Gramm Erdbeeren 50g Zucker etwas
Vanille Extrakt und etwas Zitronensaft
es gibt dir die Zutaten einfach in den
Topf ich muss jetzt hier die Erdbeersoße
etwas aufkochen bei der Mischung ist es
tatsächlich ganz praktisch man
zerkleinert die Erdbeeren mit dem Beutel
und da ist einfach so ein bisschen
sofort Gelatine dabei man musste einfach
nichts kochen wenn ihr aber auf Gelatine
verzichten wollt einfach bisschen
aufkochen entweder mit aka oder ihr
kocht es so ein bisschen ein bisschen
dickflüssig wird also bis das Wasser
verdunstet ist dann kann man sich das
Bindemittel auch sparen
ist einfach den Zucker dazu
ein bisschen Zitronensaft
für den Geschmack Erdbeeren Vanille
beste Kombi und ich zerdrückst jetzt
einfach mit der wacker und kocht ein
bisschen auf
[Musik]
die Erdbeersoße ist eingekocht und ich
habe es jetzt hier umgefüllt und
abkühlen lassen wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
auch gerne durch den Sieb streichen das
habe ich auch gemacht damit einfach die
Stückchen noch zerdrückt werden und
jetzt gießt ihr sie einfach hier drüber
wie halt so eine Tomatensoße über
Spaghetti also für meinen Geschmack ist
das bisschen zu wenig etwa Soße ich
glaube ich mache noch mal die gleiche
Menge und dies ist noch mal schön voll
und dann nehme ich einfach etwas weiße
Kuvertüre und hoble sie natürlich
wie Käse einfach über die Torte aber das
ist mir tatsächlich ein bisschen zu
wenig Erdbeeren machen wir einfach noch
mal die Menge
[Musik]
jetzt kann die Torte probiert werden
ich würde gerne so wie bei euch jetzt
mit dem Eis so
okay ich muss sagen ich finde optisch
finde ich die Torte gewöhnungsbedürftig
also ganz offen gesprochen ist nicht so
mein Stil ich finde es cool wie
Spaghetti ja toll
[Musik]
aber es ist super einfach zum Nachmachen
weil man eigentlich gar keine Technik
beachten muss mit dem Spritzbeutel
einfach die Creme so aufspritzt und wenn
man diese Optik nicht möchte aber
trotzdem den Geschmack möchte kann man
ja auch die Kuppel einfach schön
verstreichen oder mit einem Löffel
Muster reinziehen oder wenn es euch so
gefällt einfach so so original
vanilleeisig übrigens das meist gegessen
in Deutschland und ich muss sagen
dass die Sahne unten ist das Eis oben
drauf und dann gefriert ja die Sahne so
ein bisschen und wenn ich mir Eisbecher
bestelle ich immer Sahne unten rein
ehrlich jetzt der schmeckt echt genial
okay die perfekte sind
also bei Susi und Strolch ist das
Verhältnis zwischen wer ist wie viel
schon ausgeglichen
ich hatte eine Gabel voll und er hat das
ganze Stück gegessen seht ihr das dann
sagt er ich bin schuld daran
okay
wenn du halt 99% von allem ist und mir
das so übrig bleibt
aber die schmeckt echt genial ohne es
ist eine leckere Torte ehrlich jetzt
ohne Witz
also probiert das Rezept gerne aus
dürfen wir nichts übrig gelassen
ich dachte immer was meines ist auch
dein und anders
eine ganz ganz tolle leckere Torte genau
probiert gerne das Rezept aus oder wenn
ihr sagt ich mache lieber Backmischung
macht halt die Backmischung ist drauf
okay mein Gott es ist halt so also das
Rezept ist super schmeckt uns sehr gut
schmeckt fruchtig statt Erdbeeren könnt
ihr auch Himbeeren zum Beispiel
verwenden
und ihr findet alle Infos in meiner App
oder auch
bis zum nächsten Mal und falls ihr
Wünsche habt für das nächste nachgemacht
Video einfach in die Kommentare
schreiben
tolle Videos sehen wollt Abonniert den
Kanal ja mach's gut
[Musik]